The Star Wars universe is a pretty complex
place, and it gets a little more complex with
every episode of Rebels, every tie-in comic
and novel, and best of all, when a highly
continuity-dependent movie like Rogue One
is released.
Every tenuous connection makes the experience
a little richer, no matter how hard the director
tries to hide these things in the fabric of
the film.
Here are a few Rogue One Easter eggs you didn't
notice.
Oh, and if you haven't seen Rogue One yet,
brace for impact: spoilers ahead!
Blue Harvest
What is it with young rebels and blue milk?
As a very young Jyn escapes her family's farm
at the beginning of Rogue One, we see a glass
of blue milk perched on a countertop, not
unlike the questionable beverage that young
Luke Skywalker had to endure in A New Hope.
The blue moo juice also reappears in Attack
of the Clones.
Presumably, the junk comes from banthas, but
no one is free from it, even on planets where
banthas aren't a native species.
Someone is importing this junk.
Forget about buildi ng a Death Star, just
corner the blue milk market if you want to
conquer the galaxy.
Where there's a Whill…
Back when Star Wars was just a shadow of an
idea in the curly head of George Lucas, it
was called Journal of the Whills.
The concept of an ancient race of aliens deeply
connected to the Force has floated around
the Star Wars universe since the beginning,
but nothing really definitive has been established
about them … except for that they absolutely
have nothing to with Yoda's unknown species.
Lo and behold, the desert city of Jedha was
actually home to the Temple of the Whills,
once guarded by the blind Chirrut Îmwe and
freelance assassin Baze Malbus.
The bustling, mysterious city has super-deep
ties to the whole Jedi thing, which is reinforced
by the fallen Jedi statues around the surface
and the fact that it's absolutely full of
kyber crystals, used to make lightsabers.
Jedha … Jedi … it can't be a coincidence.
And now it's exploded.
The not-so-good Doctor
It's a cameo that's impossible to miss.
In the ill-fated city of Jedha, Jyn Erso and
Cassian Andor bump into a really, really ugly
man and his walrus-faced pal.
Visitors to Chalmun's Cantina on Tatooine
will easily recognize the duo as Dr. Evazan
and Ponda Baba, who try to start trouble with
Luke Skywalker and lose an arm to Obi-Wan's
saber for the trouble.
Apparently, Ponda Baba could easily escape
a city going totally nuclear, but couldn't
keep his arms from falling off his body in
a sleazy bar a few weeks later.
Tough break, buddy.
The worst job in the universe
Directing the as-yet-untitled Star Wars: Episode
VIII would be a dream job for just about any
director, and as you probably know, Rian Johnson
scored the gig after directing a few episodes
of Breaking Bad and writing the screenplay
for Episode VIII.
But he also got the absolute worst gig in
the galaxy: standing next to the deadly, planet-destroying,
railing-less laser shaft in the Death Star.
"I just want a railing.
You know, one railing, right here!"
"Yeah I know I've almost fallen over that
thing so many times."
It's a cameo we wouldn't even know about if
Johnson himself didn't tell us at 2016's Star
Wars Celebration in London.
So let us not forget that not only did Galen
Erso built a vulnerable exhaust port into
the Death Star, but he subtly made these guys
lives a living hell.
For the Rebellion.
Budget dejarik and cave monsters
There are a lot of scummy things going on
in Saw Gerrera's ramshackle base, including,
but not limited to, watching weird holo-porn
of dancing Twi'leks … which only reminds
us of Grandpa Itchy's dirty dalliances in
the forbidden Star Wars Holiday Special.
"Oh, we are excited, aren't we?"
But amid the many props and baubles found
in the base is a very bootleg version of dejarik,
the holographic chess game found aboard the
Millennium Falcon.
This dollar store version uses actual, physical
pieces and not the hi-tech, animated, holographic
stuff.
Which is what you get when you blow your whole
hologram budget on dancing girls.
Also making an appearance in Gerrera's cave
in especially Easter-eggy form are creatures
from director Gareth Edward's 2010 film Monsters
and his 2014 film Godzilla.
The director told The Star Wars Show that
it wasn't even him being cheeky; these were
slipped into Gerrera's cave by the crew.
Like father, like son
Like all good supervillains, Darth Vader has
to have a sweet and scary base.
We've only ever really seen him hanging out
on giant starships, but early concepts for
the character placed him in his very own Snake
Mountain, by the name of Bast Castle, on the
beaches of an acid rain planet called , where
real estate is probably cheaper than Detroit.
While Rogue One flips the script a bit, and
thankfully, his base doesn't just look like
a giant version of his own helmet, because
that design was stolen by the Legion of Doom.
Vader apparently chills on a fiery lava planet,
which is presumably Mustafar, the very same
place he lost most of his body parts and caught
on fire courtesy of Obi-Wan Kenobi.
Because there's nothing like building a home
on the shores of the lake where your humanity
and dignity drowned.
And of course, Vader has to take his cumbersome
costume off occasionally, right?
We learn that in order to rejuvenate his half-robot
body, he goes swimming in his own personal
bacta tank, extremely similar to the one we
see Luke in, recovering from frostbite and
some serious wampa wounds.
Though a sassy wampa-slap is a lot less serious
than, you know, losing all your limbs.
The Rebels connection
Early intel for Rogue One was adamant about
the film having nothing to do with the ongoing
animated series, Rebels, but now that seems
like a bit of misdirection, for a few reasons.
First, it looks a lot like the Rebels ship
Ghost is spotted among the fighters during
the film's final battle, indicated by the
unique pattern of lights on the rear of the
ship.
There aren't too many ships' butts that look
like a surprised clown, but the Ghost is one
of them.
Second, the name "General Syndulla" is mentioned,
and unless "Syndulla" is the "Jones" or "Smith"
of the galaxy, that would have to be Hera
Syndulla, the captain of the Ghost.
Some viewers have also speculated on the use
of the name "Blacksaber" as one of the Empire's
projects, mentioned as Jyn is searching the
archives and just before she lands on the
file she's searching for, "Stardust."
While there are a lot of sabers in the universe,
the darksaber is an ancient Jedi artifact
once stolen by the Mandalorians and then wielded
by Darth Maul, and yes, it has a black blade.
"Blacksaber" could refer to just about anything,
though, from Darth Vader's towering, hellish
home, to an undisclosed death weapon, to Grand
Moff Tarkin's favorite pie recipe.
Time will tell.
Blasting womp rats
Luke Skywalker, even though he'd one day become
a noble Jedi, was a jerk of a kid.
To quash his boredom on Tatooine, he'd hop
into his T-16 Skyhopper and fly around blasting
womp rats.
Apparently, his love of fun is shared by Stormtroopers,
too, since two helmet-heads can be heard on
Scarif idly chattering about how the old T-15
models were getting phased out.
Do Stormtroopers go on joyrides, or is it
just an endless nightmare of anxiety until
a rebel blows you up or a slightly perturbed
Darth Vader crunches your windpipe?
We hope it's the former.
Red Five
The Rebel Alliance existed long before a shaggy-haired
farmboy-turned-Jedi came along to save it.
While Luke was out collecting moisture in
the desert and whining about not going to
Tosche Station, a real rebel soldier was flying
around in an X-wing with the callsign Red
Five … until he exploded during the attack
on Scarif.
A little while later, Luke would take the
same callsign during the Battle of Yavin,
destroying the first Death Star.
Since, you know, no one was using it anymore.
But he wasn't the only hotshot pilot, and
he wasn't even the boss.
The head of the Red Squadron, Garven Dreis,
survived the attack on Scarif and went on
to attack the Death Star at the Battle of
Yavin.
Original actor Drewe Henley came back to play
the role, at least via some amazing CGI work,
since Henley was 76 at the time, and passed
away 10 months before the film reached theaters.
He can consider himself in some pretty solid,
posthumous company.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!